if we have a circle with radius r then
its area is pi r squared but why so
let's see
let's take a circle and divide it into
parts these parts are called sectors if
we take these sectors and keep them
vertically then the figure will look
somewhat like this and if you divide the
circle into more sectors and we keep
figures like this then the combined
figure will look like this
can you tell me what this figure looks
like
yes it looks like a rectangle and if you
notice this length is equal to the
radius this will be r and the addition
of the upper and lower lengths will be 2
pi r because they total nothing but the
entire boundary of the circumference so
the length above will be pi r and the
length below will also be pi r
and the area of the rectangle is its
length multiplied by its breadth so
multiplying these two we get pi r
multiplied by r which is pi r squared so
now we know why the area of a circle is
pi r squared in the next video we shall
see one more concept which will prove
this for more such interesting math
concepts please subscribe to our youtube
channel